is getting more brazen in chicago after
a police officer is gunned down during a
routine traffic stop 29-year-old officer
ella french was killed in the line of
duty while her partner remains in
critical condition after being shot
three times sadly the carnage doesn't
end there this past weekend alone 73
people were shot and 10 were killed in
the windy city despite this out of
control violence democrat cory bush is
doubling down on her call to defund
police
you said you have your own security
while almost in the same breath
advocating for defunding the police the
reason why we have these problems is
because those that were in power and
could have fixed this problem before now
didn't and cost it cost lives we're
adding more money to the police but but
we're still dying
to change
so you know katie we just got done
talking about essentially two classes of
people in this country elites corey
bush's position it seems to be when it
comes to the police and personal
protection is that she is more important
than everyone else her position doesn't
seem to be just let them eat cake it's
let them eat lead yeah absolutely
and you know officer ella french wanted
to be make a difference in her community
she signed up for this dangerous job in
one of the most dangerous cities in the
entire world
and she woke up that day to go do her
job and to try and help and she got a
call that ended her life and there are
dozens of other officers around the
country who have suffered the same fate
and you have the mayor making statements
and you have people like corey bush who
have implemented this leftist ideology
in cities across the country at the
ameri the mayor level at the prosecutor
prosecution level and criminals are in
charge and it doesn't seem like they're
doing anything to make sure
that this doesn't keep happening and you
know cory bush keeps arguing she wants
more social workers to be involved well
call a social worker to deal with a
dangerous situation where someone will
respond to a traffic stop with lethal
force and there are police officers
every day who get up
to serve their communities to make a
difference they don't go home they have
families too and if you want to really
understand how this all went down listen
to the police scanner because that will
give you a whole different perspective
on this entire debate dana well she that
was just going to mention that
to corey bush's point if you follow her
logic
to the extent there is any
routine traffic stops should end
and why do you have routine traffic
stops well because there was a call and
it says this could be a problem turns
out actually the feds just
um arrested right before we came on air
a straw gun purchaser so somebody bought
the gun for the guy now that guy's in
trouble as well um and her brother the
officer's brother said
he is an iraq war veteran so this this
family was all about public service and
he was devastated he said like the god
took the wrong kid is what he said here
and i thought that the police
superintendent there he said no one's
going to march or protest yes for her
and and that's a shame i'm not i don't
know i'm not suggesting people
protest and march in the street or write
i'm not suggesting that but he makes a
really good point on where we put our
values
you know uh jessica mayor laurie
lightfoot wants to move this away from
being a political issue at least to
defund the police political issue she
wants to actually focus it on a
different political issue let's watch
what she had to say and i'll get your
response
the police are not our enemies
they are human
just as we are
flawed
just as we are
we have a common enemy
it's the guns
and the gangs
see jessica this is a story about guns
it is a political issue but not defund
the police gun control i
it's all the things and i wish that
people it takes too long unfortunately i
mean we have an hour show which is a
huge privilege to be able to revisit
topics and to get everyone's opinion on
that and unfortunately that's just not
how the news works and there are so many
tragic angles to this and yes guns are
part of the problem and someone who sold
a gun to someone who had a felony
charge beforehand and that person is
going to be in trouble as well it's a
problem that majority of the guns that
get used in some of these
in these cities come from conservative
states with looser laws and then they
get bust across the border and then they
get used in chicago um but
i do want to
i don't want to be like oh they're
silver lining in this because it's a
tragedy to lose a life i'm happy to hear
more nuance to these discussions from
people in positions of power who are
moving away from just straight up like
this is about cops that gunned down
unarmed people that we need to celebrate
those in law enforcement who do risk
their lives every day and we also need
to talk about the victims the unarmed
victims but the police officers
in the way that they should be and
that's something that eric adams who
will go on to be the mayor of new york
city has done really well where he names
the officers who have been
shot and gunned down themselves and
victims as well you know greg not every
story is a media criticism story but to
her point to jessica's point in 2019
there were 14 unarmed black men killed
by police in that same year 51 officers
killed in the line of duty i don't think
americans understand that context in
fact i know they don't if you ask most
people how many unknown black men are
killed every year they get it wildly
wrong regardless of political
affiliation yeah the uh
every time there were riots or
demonstrations and arson what predated
it it was a video of a tragic ugly uh
event involving either the death of an
unarmed uh suspect
um you could like the media if they
wanted to they could spend
two hours every day and look at each
case that happens through the year
because there's not a lot there's like
if you add the if you add black and
white and and i guess other other
non-white it's probably about two dozen
thirty maybe i i i i in in
that was 2019 from washington from their
washington post data so i would suggest
that like yeah people should get in
other people's faces it's time it's like
if you
if the media if we had video of the
death of this police officer and we
played it as much as the george floyd
video
what would happen we will never know
because that will never happen we will
never treat the death of a police
officer as importantly as we would in
any other case i understand it because
you could say that what one is an
authority and one is in and one is armed
and one is i get it but if you look at
every single one of these cases they are
so nuanced
right and it's like and you start saying
okay now i see this is like a really
really hard job it's a really hard job
and we demonized an entire force
which then led to this def
obviously the defunding but also the
ferguson effect and the
dramatic rise in crime meanwhile i say
this all the time lori lightfoot is
depending on what what is what she's
calling the national problem of gun
violence
that's to paper over the fact that the
national problem is crime right whenever
they talk about crime they go that's a
local problem but the guns are a
national problem no no no they're both
the same okay so they're both a national
problem
all right hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else